good morning deputy prime minister good
morning
what can you tell us this morning about
the state of the russian advance
particularly on the key cities of kiev
odessa and mario paul well of course
putin came in and had sold to the
russian people but also to his
conscripts on the ground in ukraine that
this would be far easier than it's
turned out that is partly a testament to
the resilience and the courage of the
ukrainian people and of course we've
been supporting them with uh training
through uh operation orbital which has
trained over 22 000 ukrainian armed
forces also the anti-tank missiles 2000
that we provided them and the wider
international community but they have
definitely proved
a tougher prospect than putin expected
and that has an effect on morale on the
russian side as well
of course at the same time we've imposed
the biggest sanctions package i can
remember
with
devastating consequences in terms of the
ruble falling to record low
the stock market and also we've seen the
russian central bank which itself has
been subject to sanctions doubling
interest rates that has put the squeeze
on putin what he's now doing is
responding with ever more brutal tactics
to try and rest back the initiative i
think the bottom line is none of the
major cities have yet fallen but i think
we are ought to be under no doubt that
our mission with our allies is to ensure
putin fails in ukraine and he's going to
take some time
we're talking about months if not years
and therefore we'll have to show
some strategic stamina because this is
not going to be over in days well let's
unpack some of that and let's deal with
some of the immediate issues the red
cross says that the russians have broken
the ceasefire by shelling civilians
this is actually your own professional
field as a
lawyer and you've prosecuted war
criminals
um this must be a war crime mustn't it
well you're right the the
reckless and uh frankly appalling
tactics by the putin regime
must be held to account not just putin
himself but also anyone taking illegal
orders and so on top of the 220 million
pounds of humanitarian support we're
providing uh to the ukrainian people
we're also very clear that as the
international criminal court opens uh
its examination of what's taking place
and it's right that a court decides
whether war crimes have been committed
we will provide the support diplomatic
support we've been part of the countries
that have referred this to the icc but
also we've got a history from nuremberg
onwards of supporting war crimes uh
prosecutions whether it's through
forensic evidence and or or right the
way through of course charles taylor um
radhavan caridita here in
british jails
and
uh we'll do whatever it takes we've got
a huge amount of experience i would also
just say it's part of what we do as a
country as a force for good you have a a
british prosecutor at the icc there's a
british judge joe corner they're
independent but it is part of what we do
to support those institutions and hold
putin to account just to be clear
someone can be prosecuted in absentia
they don't have to be there at the icc
and um
it doesn't actually matter that you
might say
a commander might say i was only
following orders just to be absolutely
clear anybody who
takes steps that will be defined as a
war crime
can be and will be prosecuted if you
have your way at the icc whether they
turn up they don't turn up whether they
are the putin himself or their captain
on the ground of course the the the the
icc is independent we need to respect
the prosecutorial judicial independence
so these are decisions for them to make
what i'm saying is it is absolutely
right that there is rigorous full
accountability for anything that happens
and the fact that the icc is looking at
this is something that we don't just
support as a
if you like political uh
measure because we're a state party to
the icc but also we will do what it
takes with nuts and bolts cooperation to
try and help them and
and the point i guess at this point in
time while that conflict is raging is to
preserve as much evidence as we can and
they need to know this is your point
well my point the here and now in all of
this is i want and we want and the icc
is making clear that for all of those
commanders on the ground right through
to the people around putin in the
kremlin what they do now whether they
give or whether they follow illegal
orders to commit war crimes they will be
held to account for it and they need to
know that and will it affect morale it
often does in these types of situation
you um and i've spoken before about your
own family's flight from the nuts
invasion of czechoslovakia
more than a million people are fleeing
ukraine the u.n says maybe a million and
a half of cross borders what are we
doing to help people get out to
neighbouring states
well we've as i said we've provided over
200 million pounds in uh humanitarian
assistance we'll work with the
international agencies obviously the u.n
and those european countries that are
closest to ukraine it always happens
that people want to go if they have to
leave their home country and that is
hugely traumatic they'll want to go or
they tend to want to go to places which
are as close as possible because they'll
want to go back as soon as conditions on
the ground help we've also made it clear
both in relation to dependence of brits
here who ukrainian or ukrainians living
here that we will
provide the visa flexibility so we
estimate up to 200 000 could come here
and on top of that there is a
humanitarian protection
mechanism that the home secretary set up
to allow the charitable business or
individual sponsorship of those to come
here from ukraine i want to come to um
the
the visa
regime in a moment but just sticking
with
what is happening on the borders there
um
we've seen in recent times the flow of
civilians from
uh conflicts being used essentially
weaponized to destabilize other states
belarus did that and so on are you
concerned that
putin will use this flow to destabilize
poland moldova romania
or frankly as human shields for his own
troops i think anything is possible
where you look at what putin has done in
the past in all the wars he's been
involved in you look at the tactics in
syria i don't think that there is any
tactic he wouldn't resort to but i would
say this um i think nato and central and
eastern european countries
are absolutely
resolute and we will support them to the
hilt in not allowing that to be the case
i think what putin's the impact putin
will have on nato on the resilience and
the the the result of central and
eastern european countries will be the
opposite of what he wishes i think it
will only steal their nerve and we will
support them all the way all right let's
talk about some if i can put it this way
more difficult questions
president zielinski has called for a
no-fly zone to be established
by nato nato and in particularly our
government you have responded by saying
that such a step would be
uh provoke a europe-wide conflict
surely the humanitarian crisis
uh playing out before our eyes
is going to change the calculus over
that
well i think the humanitarian situation
is something we're going to constantly
need to innovate and evolve in our
response to and i'll ultimately try and
stem and prevent but the reality is it's
not just the uk it's all of the nato
allies the u.s has been the same
european partners have been the same
we're not going to either get ourselves
into a direct military conflict with
putin either because that would be a
massive escalation but also that feeds
putin's narrative putin wants to say
that he's actually a struggle with the
west he's not this is an illegal
invasion of a neighbor whose
self-determination democratic and
territorial integrity needs to be
protected we do not want to feed putin's
narrative yeah but you've just spent
quite a lot of time telling me uh how
much money how much effort we're putting
in to protecting people the truth of the
matter is we already know that he
doesn't
uh he's not that bothered
about damage to done to civilians uh and
that the humanitarian corridors could be
uh vulnerable the american diplomat kurt
volker from whom we'll be hearing later
in this program um
said to me this week that when the
bodies start piling up in the tens of
thousands the position on the no-fly
zone will change
why not do it now and save those tens of
thousands of lives if we really really
want to protect those people the no-fly
zone even if it's limited to kiev and
the corridors of safety surely it's time
to start that now look i understand the
argument and there's head and heart in
all of this but the reality is uh we
don't think and our allies don't think
we ought to be sucked into a direct uh
military conflict with vladimir putin
and that's the position that we've taken
of course it was different if he was
attacking a nato ally the the position
around nato is very clear
but will do everything short of that to
support the ukrainians
and i understand the debate around it
well you say everything short of that
but you know how that will be heard in
ukraine we are prepared to do
anything
up to the point where it will make a
difference
well no i don't think that's true first
of all i think the efficacy of no-fly
zones if you look at history you can
think of the iraq example um
they're very difficult they're very
challenging and and
secondly if you look at the impact of
our sanctions and the uk has been at the
vanguard of the international response i
think the fact that putin and this
russian central bank have doubled
interest rates to 20
we think of what the cost of living
challenges we're facing here i do think
that that not only puts the squeeze on
the putin war machine but also it shows
the
ordinary russian people that this idea
that this is in their interest is for
the birds so at every level i think the
sanctions uh will have an impact but
they won't do so overnight indeed that's
what that's like that that is the point
the problem is
uh for the people of ukraine
overnight is what matters now is what
matters and uh
this geopolitic geopolitics of it and so
on
frankly they may appreciate but it
doesn't save them let's just deal with
point you made by the way two hundred
thousand
people you think may come to the united
kingdom
now uh last week your colleague lis
trust said to me that uh
at the same time on sunday
us uk couldn't commit to admitting any
ukrainians with family here uh by that
evening pretty patel had eased the rules
a bit and that was widely criticized and
friday night you fell into line with the
rest of the eu and admitted uh agreed to
admit people with family here the point
i'm making is why not just take the next
step now rather than having to be
dragged over days to get to do the right
thing
in fairness trevor i think if you look
uh the hong kong british national
overseas citizens if you look at
operation pitting and what we did for
those afghans fleeing and our history as
a country i think we've always stepped
up and we have here but you're right to
say that we looked and uh adjusted the
uh family dependence
that was that was a 180 degree turn your
colleague sat there and said no we can't
do that by friday night you were doing
it and absolutely responded very swiftly
um and i think that's the right thing to
do and for all the reasons that you've
given and uh and i've always felt that
we should be open-hearted by the way um
you know you
on that uh if we started abrogating
security checks on those coming from a
war zone i think first of all would be
the wrong thing to do uh we've got to
look at our security secondly i think
you see public support which has been
incredible very moving and overwhelming
i think you would start to see that
phrase in the same way as let's be
honest if we were engaged in a military
direct conflict with vladimir putin i
think the consensus about what we're
doing would also fray and so just to be
clear about this uh you've got to think
these things through and we've got to be
measured as well as resolute all right
look but
isn't the point here
that what seems to happen is not so much
that you're reacting to events but
you're being dragged to events and that
actually what you're really doing is
following
rather than leading on sanctions on the
refugees you've issued stirring press
releases then change
the position uh
don't you
is it
what we're seeing here a government
which doesn't want to take the political
risks that are actually involved in
truly confronting putin well i i just
don't think that's true on the facts if
i may say so trevor let me give you the
example of sanctions we were out ahead
and if you take russian banks we have
sanctioned more russian banks in the eu
including spur bank the biggest russian
bank if you take russian companies three
million are subject to restrictions
which means they can't raise finance or
be listed in the uk that was well ahead
of anything the eu has done uh it's true
that the sanctions approach of the us
and the eu and the uk they're not
identical but but but i'm afraid i do
not accept your opposition i've been at
the vanguard and actually if you talk to
ordinary ukrainians indeed the ukrainian
ambassador he has paid tribute and they
pay tribute to the resolve and the
solidarity we show all right let's let's
take a a very practical exam three weeks
ago uh liz trust told me that putin's
friends and associates this is her word
would have no place to hide um
take a look at a picture i'm going to
show you this is a gentleman called
general sergey shoigu he is the russian
defense minister
he should turn up here here he is there
is
mr putin's closest associate
running the uh he's running the campaign
he met our own defense minister three
weeks ago on february 23rd day before
the invasion
sanctioned by the eu two days later
sanctioned by the usa
11 days after the russians invaded he is
still not sanctioned by us why not look
i'm always very careful not to talk
about individuals because in relation to
criminal prosecutions or sanctions but
let me answer the question but let me
answer the question squarely but it's
not right actually to for me to
pre-judge all uh any legal action we
take it's very serious it needs to be
done on the evidence and on the legal
days yeah but these things you need to
have evidence that he has got assets
here so the eu and the
and the usa are basically breaching
proper proper legal well i don't know in
relation
first of all he's got you've got to have
evidence of the legal criteria he's also
got to have assets
uh if you're talking about immediate
action against assets in the uk so we do
have to we didn't have the rule of law
in this country we do do these things uh
carefully but uh and as a result of that
by the way we have far more impact when
i introduced the sergey magnitsky
sanctions for human rights abuses but
also for corruption based on the biggest
tax fraud in russian history uh we we
had all of these arguments about whether
we moved more quickly which we did in
many cases also but the reality is we
avoided successful legal challenge
against those sanctions nothing would be
a greater pr coup for putin than if we
put sanctions on someone and then we
found they were successfully appealed so
we do act swiftly okay and that is
important we also need to need to make
sure we can do so sustainably because
that's where the credibility will you
then stop your colleague the prime
minister going about saying that we've
sanctioned a hundred people we've it's
over a hundred uh entities and i think
if you take since uh 2014 250
individuals have been sanctioned
but
this person who has been sanctioned by
pretty much everybody else isn't
sanctioned by us you'll always be able
to do this um uh trevor you're about to
point out that one or other if you take
the picture overall and look not just at
individuals but the corporate uh
uh vehicles that they uh have assets uh
through banks companies as well as the
individuals i i
we yield to no one in our record they're
not just moving swiftly but also
robustly and again those figures on
banks and companies three million
russian companies and often you find the
associates or the individuals are
operating through those businesses or
banks uh account now list on the uk
stock market cannot now raise money uh
loans in the uk all right well let's
talk about uh how far we're prepared to
go the
wars already caused a huge spike in
energy costs
um when you're going to tell the british
people that
they are going to have to pay
a price here
and by the way might it not be the
moment for you to think again about that
national insurance tax rise of one and a
quarter per cent given the pain that
we're going to have to face well look
first of all uh in terms of the uh the
the funding of social care i think we
should be dealing with the social care
problem it's been docked uh by
successive governments i'm proud that
this government is going to deal with
the social care challenge that so many
people face on energy prices we've been
very clear if you have a global crisis a
conflict involving
russia or any other oil gas producer
it's going to have an impact on global
prices in fact we get just four percent
of our gas from
russia so we are uh
we are much less reliant than others um
but what we're going to do in terms of
supply is keep expanding the renewables
we're going to invest more
in nuclear particularly those small
nuclear reactors and we're also going to
make sure we can rely for resilience on
the north side but the price the price
of energy is going to go up
we know that so let me tell you the only
way you're going to be able to protect
people is by expanding supply so
are you going to tell people that
they're going to pay a thousand and plus
more or by the way are you going to
think about returning to coal or
fracking no we're not going to do
something we're not going to return to
coal but i've given you the three areas
north the old production where we'll
have more resilience renewables and
nuclear where we do need to increase
supply and that is already part of our
strategy in terms of protecting
consumers i mean just to be clear the
chancellor and the prime minister have
put 20 billion pounds into the cost of
living challenge that we face right now
to protect consumers nine billion of
that is to support with energy bills uh
so from the uh winter fuel payments
through to the the discounts and the
rebates on council tax and energy bills
we're already providing this support to
make sure we can see ourselves through
what we hope will be a temporary crisis
all right
let's talk uh very briefly now about the
potential end game
mr putin has said overnight that
sanctions are an act of war
do you fear that
a cornered isolated kremlin with its
troops bogged down in a
conflict that mr putin didn't anticipate
could actually reach for the nuclear
button
now i think the the debate and the
rhetoric around that is just that um but
what it does show you i mean first of
all just to be clear sanctions are not
an act of war international law is very
clear about that our sanctions are
entirely both legally justified but also
proportionate to what we're trying to
deal with but what it does show you is
that this has not been the cakewalk
putin expected and it's not just us
hearing that message it's russian people
and those russian conscripts who were
told they were peacekeepers in ukraine
who were finding fearsome resistance
from the ukrainians but but this was not
what what uh their their
commander-in-chief had promised them but
i should say to you that he has said i
think it's come out this morning by the
russian news agency that ukraine is
developing a dirty nuclear bomb
no evidence for that whatsoever
but could that be preparation on his
part for an escalation to the use of
what
i think
ludicrously but anyway are called
battlefield nuclear weapons i i think
it's rhetoric and brinkmanship and uh
putin's at various times i mean he's got
a track record as long as anyone's armed
uh of misinformation and propaganda we
saw that through the pandemic and this
is a distraction from what the real
issues are at hand which is that uh it's
an inva illegal invasion uh and it is
not going according to plan you're
absolutely right though trevor to say uh
that makes him even more unpredictable
uh and uh that's why working in the un
working with our nato allies working
with our international partners around
the world i mean china has got uh a job
here they've got to step up as well this
is a permanent member of the security
council um india as well so we need to
expand the diplomatic pressure um but
but let's not get distracted by the the
propaganda of putin deputy prime
minister thank you so much